look you know I think with a debate like
this it should be about policies it
shouldn't be about personalities and
it's easy for me to have a dig at Tony
Blair we could just to send it to a
personal thank you max I think the issue
about left or right I think's a bit
misleading to be honest I don't think
outside politico's maybe like me and
yourself and the other row in most
people don't think in terms of left or
right they think in terms of issues to
be addressed in a way that's convincing
in coherent that resonates with their
experiences told in our language they
understand and the trip for labor or for
any left coalition is to build up
support amongst low income and middle
income people that's the majority of
society and anyone standing for the
labor leader ship has to prove that now
I actually think you don't actually have
to stick to the old New Labour PlayBook
there are lots of things which went
wrong like the Iraq war for example like
abolishing at the 10p rate of tax back
then
like not regulating the city that went
wrong and I think it's possible to have
a different approach which helps stand
up for people who are underrepresented
in society but also middle-income people
as well okay I do the gags just to be
clear young man Owen Bennett as far as
you're concerned it are they wrong to
have four separate candidates on the on
the leadership ballot paper and also has
it gone on for too long I don't think
they're going to have four on there
don't give some maths with the numbers I
think is it going on too long it
certainly feels like yeah I don't even
know if we're halfway through yet and I
don't know how much more we're going to
get from these hustings we've already
that we have had already but I'd like to
say to you know pick up Owen Jones's
point he says let's not talk in terms of
left and right and then he says only the
left-wing coalition so he's using the
terms east and I said oh sorry just to
clarify that in terms of a political
movement labour has to build a broad
coalition of working people the majority
of society people who keep society
ticking down today that's a low-income
and middle-income people alike well I
don't see how you can build this broad
coalition if you take the very aspects
of the previous campaign which hasn't
worked and try and use that as a base
somehow to try and reach out to people
who vote too conservative I mean I can't
think of a single person who voted for
David Cameron in 2015 you see Jeremy
Corbyn become due to the Labour Party at
all that's the answer that I was looking
for I'm gonna vote for labour
now I just they think you are just
living in fantasy world really winters
of the last election is it hemorrhage
support all over the place it lost 40
seats of course to the Scottish National
Party a party which positioned itself to
the left of the Labour Party that have
had a real impact in England and Wales
as well because a huge number of voters
were concerned about the idea and it was
drummed into them by the media a lot of
this idea that labour could only come to
power backed up by a party which wanted
to break up the country and so on but
actually it's about people as well who
didn't vote of what we've seen it's a
terrible play and indictment of our
democracy that with every election
almost in the last few years since the
early 90s turnout has plummeted I think
what labour needs to do not talk again
about left or right what about the
self-employed one-in-seven work is now
self-employed often their income falling
lacking security no paid sick leave
maternity leave those are the sorts of
issues actually which I think affect
people in the middle or if you're
talking about Tories I know a lot of
furious commuters middle-class living
around London who are ripped off by a
railway companies and that's why I think
it's a sensible centre ground policy to
say let's bring the railways back under
the control of those people in this
country that's not what we're here to
talk about today we're talking about
today we're here to talk about the
candidates and what they are bringing to
the party or otherwise and I suppose
though in bailant the question is if
Jeremy Corbyn does win and this latest
poll it's only one poll and you know
they were all here what they would say
about that they've got another hustings
tonight but it is one poll it is putting
him very much in the lead do you think
that there could be a split within the
party like we saw with the SDP if he is
the leader of the Labour Party we heard
from Yvette Cooper for example who said
she didn't want to be in his cabinet I
think you're gonna see you won't see a
cabinet of many talents certainly of
Corbin's lead Ignace the cabinet of
people who subscribes his views it's not
actually that many of the Labour
parliamentary party he had to basically
or people had to beg on his behalf just
to get on the nomination papers he
hasn't got a broad support in the PLP
but I think well I would just say to
Owen Jones talks about the SNP there you
piggy undermined his own argument
because if you're saying this is this
SNP party which is answer your stereo to
doing so well in Scotland where people
in England had the chance to put them in
come
by voting for labour they could about
what would sounds like be your dream
ticket of a Labour SNP coalition and see
austerity all that kind of stuff the
voters they don't want that the vote
just gave their decision on that two
months ago they did not what now I can't
for the life of me think while you're
espousing that should be the way to go I
mean Owen mark team the point that was
making was that actually what really
resident you are older than me so yes
mum aged better than others but no but
the point the point I was making
actually was the reason that really
resonated with people was above all else
the sense the fear that the SNP were
Party committed to breaking up the
country that's what hugely tapped into a
sense of resentment amongst many English
traitors and I came across that time and
time again and the point just responds
okay as well I don't think there's a
point of having a discussion if it's
just about personalities got to talk
about the policies as well and what
they're actually proposing to bring to
the country now I think standing up for
self-employed people who like rights
standing up for utilities run by the
people of this country instead of
foreign governments and profiteering
companies for example but actually we
deal the housing crisis particularly for
the next generation you can't often
afford either to get their own home or
to get a council house or they're ripped
off by private landlords I just think
these are the issues we need to be
talking about and all too often it's all
about personality okay okay let me ask
you in Jones about the parties splitting
lots of people tweeting this afternoon
saying there will be a new party called
the Democratic Party they'll join forces
with the Lib Dems and the Greens join us
for the green this sounds a bit odd
given I would suggest that obviously
people like supporting Jeremy Corbyn
would just find more common cause with
the greens than than a new party
splitting away from labour on the right
reject out of hand that there could be a
new party well I said he I certainly
think that would be pretty disastrous if
the right of the party marched off and
did that because in the 1980s look what
happened they got a derisory number of
seats because of the nature of the
electoral system and it just helps split
the ante Tory vote I think above all
else actually what we need is well the
right the party obviously left in the
1980s and I think because people like
Tony Bennett taken over the party
dragged it to the left
mainly completely unelectable I mean
you've only gone
history I don't understand why you play
with the right so the problem is this
you know this you can have a situation
where one wing of the party throws its
toys out the pram because of a result
they don't like the left I have to say
often gritted their teeth a pop up with
for example Tony blight even when he
invaded Iraq they didn't March off on
block with all their own pieces set up a
new party the point about the Labour
Party is it has to be a broad coalition
and that is whoever is leader whether
they hail from the left or the right of
the party they have to build a broad
coalition of people and then go to the
country and unite people low income
middle income alike to build a majority
and that that's what it has to come down
to I think it's sad to talk about you
know splits and setting up new parties
in that way because people don't like
the democratic results of it of an
election do you think Jeremy Corbyn can
prove that build that broad coalition
and evening albans the mass to go out
and convince the people who were
starting their own job starting their
own companies boat was called
nationalize everything email a headline
generator I think at the end of the day
he has to prove yes what were you saying
no I mean the thing that I'm in Jones
and I think it's wonderful these careers
going so well it's now in the 1% of
earners in this country and I but you
know the people that have to actually
care about you know we talk about how
they're going to pay the bills need a
government that's based in the center
ground to attract votes from the Tories
the reason why the Tories are doing
these things are in Jones isn't like
it's because they've in power
why are they in power because the Labour
Party seems to left-wing at the last
nation they didn't say more more to the
left they're not gonna win again I think
it's a show you've sorts of personal
comments as I've said and what labour
needs because I don't think the people
out there think in terms of left or
right they think in terms of issues
let's have a Labour leadership but
actually inspires people offers a
coherent agenda I'd like to see whoever
wins the Labour leadership do that I
think you know they shouldn't be these
talks of splits divisions I don't think
people should get personal in that way
let's just have a friendly debate about
issues instead of personality dollar do
you think Jeremy Corbyn is the best man
to be the Labour Party I think what he's
showing to it through this campaign is
he's coming actually bringing ideas and
policies to the agenda and the reason
he's doing so much better at the moment
than Evette keep an Andy Burnham le
scandal against all those odds is
because they haven't offered at the
moment a genuine inspiring alternative
if they want to beat Jeremy Corbyn then
they need to bring
the table genuine policies that inspire
people that's how you before we let you
go final thought on bone it to you first
of all with friends like Tony Blair who
Nate who needs enemies does it help that
he gets involved does the man who led
the Labour Party to three general
election victories for the first time in
the history does it help when he gets
involved I think if I was a member the
Labour Party yeah I think it should tell
you to listen to what tiny birds got to
say I know it's very easy for rowing
Jones talked about a lot people like
Emma Jones talk about Iraq and this kind
of thing what about the minimum wage
what about tax credits what about sure
start I mean you know if Owen Jones and
labels aren't gonna fend these these
achievements of Tony Blair's government
as they would see them who is well
ironically that's exactly what people
like me of doing it was me who defended
the charge of new labor that they spent
too much money which the Tories backed
no they didn't it's me who's defended
tax credits a few days ago when the
Tories launched an all-out assault on
them which low paid workers depend on
when the Labour leadership refused to
support that is me he supports the
public investment or why don't you start
Labor Party for the last thirteen years
okay public money which investment
that's how be taken away thank you very
much indeed for joining us here on Sky
News this afternoon last word to our
colleague Matt Shirley who works for the
Daily Mail he says hashtag Owen me Owen
you aha we like that was funny wasn't it
it's funny Thank You funnier than you
too thanks a lot for joining